a Roomba you're this is like a little
baby Roomba just going
um
[Music]
going my name is
and today I'm going to be taking you
through my morning routine usually I get
my hair out of my face and it's not
always the most glamorous look like I
don't have
I don't have the Harry Styles uh man bun
cool thing that goes on so the first
step is washing your face here look we
got this
so I guess let's get into it first right
people especially in adolescents people
were like
oh man you need to start doing stuff for
your skin
getting out of hand and and especially
as I started to grow facial hair it
really um started to mess up with my
skin it started off with just a like
just this basically just washing my face
and then eventually through family
friends and
girlfriends who were you know not happy
with just using hand soap on the face
um I was able to kind of slowly but
surely
uh level up the the face game so after
that you have this Dermalogica
daily
microfoliant basically what that means
in layman's terms little sand particles
on your face to remove all the dead skin
uh this one is probably my the most fun
step for me because I don't know it just
feels it feels nice
um so what we'll do here is we'll put it
in my hand
yay so
um and then I just put like a little a
drop or two in there
and then gets a
bit to scrubbing
[Music]
next step in the sholo routine
we'll just call it hand sanitizer for
the face it gets all the dirt out of the
pores you're a Roomba you're this is
like a little baby Roomba just going
definitely be gentle be careful around
the eyes but not super dirty so it looks
like we can move on to the next step
vitamin C
this vitamin C is for brightening your
skin I still haven't mastered how much
to do it comes in this little vial
and
I kind of just
put
and then some on the cheeks roller derby
Style on the cheeks
and then you can rub in
you don't need too much you don't want
it to be cakey right but you still want
to make sure that you're able to cover
everything
and then there you go now you're look at
you now you started your day with
vitamins look at you king that's right
next we have this now this I kind of
only use in the morning time you just
get a little
I like to be gentle around the eyes yeah
you don't need too much pressure there
they're little your eyes are little
water balloons don't poke them too hard
and after that step the eye step comes
the
moisturizer step need I say more
moisturize everyone should be
moisturizing so yeah we're just gonna
get this one everywhere this one kind of
smells like cold cucumber I like that
now the face looks a little Rosy because
you're getting the blood working
everywhere okay okay and last but not
least sunscreen
now this is one that is kind of come
into the the repertoire more recently
um because I always for the longest time
I was like I'm Brown I don't need
sunscreen like this is this is for jokes
um but then my ass got burnt and it did
not feel good so now I'm rocking the
sunscreen similar to the the kind of the
the oil that we put on earlier you want
to make sure that you know it you're
covering everything but you don't want
to you know uh plug anything up else
either so
I don't know if all of these products
are the perfect ones like I I switch out
a lot of these all the time it's it's I
it's probably unlikely that you find the
best product for your skin on the first
time so so you know don't be afraid to
to to experiments as well you know
finally there is a a bonus a bonus level
of the Skin Game and these were
introduced to me a little bit more
recently it's like an acne sort of
they're they're little dots that you put
on your face so we'll open one of these
bad boys up and they're pretty
small ish and they blend in pretty well
with with your skin tone sometimes if
I'm just like I don't care what you know
is happening today I'll just throw them
on and walk them you know throughout the
day here like I'll throw this one on
right here
um
and look at that
who that you don't even know
you can't even see
bada bang
bada boom you just did it you cleaned up
your skin thank you so much GQ and The
Grooming God segment for having me on
kind of explaining my little my
situation here
um I hope it you know uh maybe got a
couple of you guys excited about you
know getting to work on your skin I got
a couple of things coming out that I'm
excited about first and foremost Blue
Beetle August 18th
DC's New flick
it's DC summer baby you know it
um and also I got a podcast on Lobos
with my wonderful co-host Jacob Scott
Thomas Bertrand so check that out too if
you're interested and thank you